[Music]
water sustains
life on earth our ancient civilizations
flourished alongside reliable freshwater
sources
from ancient times to modern days
agricultural and livestock production
depend on this key natural resource
agriculture is the world's largest water
user
accounting for 70 percent of global
withdrawals
but pressure on fresh water resources is
increasing rapidly
in the past two decades annual fresh
water resources have declined by more
than 20 percent
population growth is a key driver of
water scarcity
socioeconomic development is another
important driver
increasing water demands and shifting
diets to more water intensive foods
moreover rising competition for scarce
water
alongside the effects of climate change
can lead to tensions and conflicts
jeopardizing access to water inevitably
vulnerable populations are the most
severely affected
fortunately we know what needs to be
done to achieve sustainable water
resource management
guaranteeing environmental flow
requirements to sustain ecosystem
functions is crucial expanding and
improving water harvesting and water
conservation techniques
can greatly benefit farmers in rain-fed
agriculture
rehabilitating and modernizing
irrigation systems and adopting
innovative technologies bolster water
productivity in irrigated cropland
and will be key to water-stressed areas
to be most effective all improved water
management practices must be combined
with the best agronomic practices
such as cultivating drought tolerant
crop varieties
non-consumptive water uses such as
aquaculture
and non-conventional water sources
including water reuse and desalination
offer further opportunities for more
responsible water resource management
effective and coordinated policies and
governance
can lead to more efficient equitable and
sustainable water resource management
our water resources are precious
together
we can ensure equitable access for all
and conserve this crucial natural
resource
for future generations